ce qui était très fatigant des choses
tout à fait étonnant c'est que vous êtes
pour le port de la cravate est pas ce
que vous dites au moins parce que c'est
une religion de l'effort le nom ça ça
c'est une petite plaisanterie que vous
êtes pour l'effort on peut être un peu
ironique en france voir encore et encore
pour le moment un petit peu vous êtes
pour le fun je suis pour les forts parce
que j'ai l'impression que que sans
efforts et on n'est pas heureux d'abord
et puis la cravate c'est une petite
plaisanterie est ce que vous faites de
l'humour alors quand vous dites je suis
pour service militaire et pour
l'uniforme et bien c'est à dire que je
crois que l'uniforme d'ailleurs même si
on le supprime le service me dit je
crois que l'uniforme est une garantie
d'égalité un effet quand on est en civil
les ans aux mots je les autres plus les
eaux 30 au moins des attentes
extrêmement téléphone tout le monde est
moche ça c'est vrai quand vous voterez
comme ça ça veut dire du cochon avaaz
échange des fonds qui seraient vais y
aller parce que ça vient du bal ça vient
d'une terreur ça vient de valence dur
général et paul personne
moi je veux pas choquant voilà le
principal but pour être choqués mais
devrait y être est ce que je ne chante
moi je vais pas choqué non j'ai rien dit
pour les stores tard jeudi tagoe livre
que tu viens pour régenter même pas
capable
quelles sont elles
etc etc cela dit le char grand garçon et
j'ai tendresse et admiration pour toi